[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
then like some hot UI changes there for
the audio but hey what's up guys it's me
your boy Eric and Joey we're back it's
not over watched today as mentioned
earlier in the week if you guys tuned in
at all we're gonna play Dragonball
fighters today yeah yeah once again with
the full version we didn't have some
problems earlier because PSN was down
but it should be fine now so a couple
things we could do today what do you
want what do you want to start with
today what's this
these guys have was it little arena
match la Morena match so I guess anyone
can open up a lobby just anywhere in
this within this Lobby yeah I was just
going for a couple online matches all
right well uh eventually do some you
know maybe Arcade Mode make sure that uh
the thing is on I've got to auto accept
the first whenever it
so yeah I think I didn't know you can
set it so that it pretty much he joins
the woman - pops - pelipper
several of reco gaming let's do it well
do local matches later maybe RK doesn't
mention if you guys want to see
something just shout out in chat all the
monitoring chat so feel free to ask some
questions
Joey's been playing the decent amount
I've played some in the office just
local stuff I haven't played too much
story or a cage but is it's bad Bulma
creatures bomb alright I don't know oh
yeah I forget that your bb Dragonball go
she's got one bar hopefully it works out
hopefully it's like beta where the
frames don't drop that we'll see part of
that is testing that I guess he has no
he now has no board no well good luck us
I want to say where I have that maker
and Victor's gonna be fine but we'll see
kind of like that weird in-between of
both supers / like maybe slightly above
the ground if it gets annoying
I can just go full game manic Scarface
27 I would assume his avatar with the
glowing ssj blue is from the pre-order
yeah so the Dana edition comes with two
special Lobby outdoors
I did not pick this team so you didn't I
I set my team I guess I forgot to set
the right default one so I guess I'm
using so enjoyed it oh it lagged just to
get to that oh is it yeah you're dead
cell there I got ya and give you okay
don't you have chunks go I'm on the wall
you're on the left
okay he's he's a day one baby and you
got you have cell oh wow okay oh he's
gonna be throwing away I tell ya he's
already done like a couple of oh we got
a H that Oh get out of here
don't be draggin Russian law dragon the
dragon Richard Speck oh they're all then
whatever the stupid chase move is super
- we gotta get me some one level 300
yeah go shoot perfecto depending on what
time to take out your there get the hell
out right PhD and to them that lag
though that been here yeah napa cabbage
is is those things they're coming for
you you played my son right did you play
at all I thought no I did so it's fine
his entire so I couldn't do it because I
forgot to preload it unfortunately and
it was like oh it is gonna take you 20
hours on your internet gotcha
real rookie mistakes through the lag
jumping between each frames and not even
do soup
I didn't I reflected off deceive all
right
no I'll straighten THC to give you two
body swap them so I can get my 16 your
pick is over the caption yeah I mean
like I said everything what's going on
go ahead why are you jinx it okay I got
I got my right here captain commando
stuff like way more shits going on and
that's also his only attack
[Music]
[Music]
well I have to just up the what can you
call out the settings or we might to set
the play local and we'll pick characters
you guys we will do our best appearances
like look at how long oh what's that
[Music]
I'm trying to still figure out how you
can even land that so do you keep the
parking spots oh you get to have it yeah
you get you think you get that's a good
question heavy funny if you lost it
please they're sparkling on our nineteen
fans
oh yeah you can well I mean anyone gonna
be able to BAC oh here we go okay I'm
trying to figure out how you can't come
over there no because there's so much
stuff on that we're putting on ps4 guys
PSN is uh not technically down it's a
little spotty though that's for sure
right also why you accept a one-bar
LMFAO says before II uh
because during the beta it was really
hard to get matches in the beta so we
left the connection open to like
anything because we couldn't find
matches however the funny thing was that
it actually turned out to be like okay
like like most of the matches I would
say during beta despite it telling us it
had red ping 80% or so give or take of
the time it was totally fine like
playable like not like that yeah that
bad I think that bad yeah so I it's we I
guess you should bump it up a little bit
maybe let's let's do that and maybe you
should make sure you have your team I
don't know how that didn't it's two
three bar yeah do you know why your team
was oh let me go check it real quick
maybe you just selected the wrong one oh
yeah yeah user this is not on Xbox we're
putting on a ps4 Pro
[Music]
I don't know though I'm gonna be the
internet right now making sure it's okay
okay we're good should have never made
that trash other team to begin with it
was one of the default you up though
yeah so you see in the corner do you
have any a new sticker things
oh wait don't do it don't do it actually
don't do I forgot that it pauses the
search yeah so we're like in a lot of
other fighting games you can't leave you
can't even go into training mode in
those like a street fight Esteban
Palmeiro says PSN is always the issue
never heard of a good experience
especially fighting it on PSN there's
been some decent ones on PSN like it
wasn't injustice like mostly fine
injustice was pretty good yeah I'm just
as - sorry yeah
Krillin come on you know you want to I
know sorry no I play the very I play
very basic characters I go Goku Goku and
Goku I haven't tried blue so yeah I was
gonna go team Doki he's a little bit
different than if not its adult Gohan
double goku for me black and freaking
super saiyan hello how can i play with
my friends so you guys would have to get
into the same like server so like west
coast one east coast one whatever that
is find out which one that is you get in
and then i think what you do is you make
like one of those arena things which is
what we saw earlier like that guy up
there like super lord like so that's
like a little arena thing that whole
lobby the other khalaby you got to make
one of those and i think we can set it
to like private potentially we're like
you can put a password in this guy's a
little keel is in savage fantasy there
we go oh three bars let's go no excuse
now and you have your team so you know
oh you know what I forgot to bring my
prop I have dragon ball three stars hair
gel thanks Mary Kay it's actually it's
just hair gel but it's in a dragon ball
like this is it turn your hair yellow no
does not nor does it give me super Sam
powers
but I was good it smells like oranges so
he says that come on bro
all right went to the bathroom yeah I
had to make the ultimate sacrifice last
name I chose Monster Hunter over
Dragonball know why I chose the last
over drug was because it wasn't loading
thanks song it's a hedgehog gaming fan
says amazing video man I like the screen
keep up the good work GameSpot thank you
9 seconds come on man but brand of hair
gel is it funny enough Felix the Cat
Gatsby I use Gatsby hair gel but the
actual dragon ball like gel I have no
idea what brand it is oh man those tape
couldn't wait to plug no I just wanted
the prop I wanted to be like hey Joey I
got Dragon Ball star 3 star here number
3 here but I don't have the rest of them
we got to go on an adventure did you
find the rest
speaking of props have you seen them I
think it was like a fast-food promotion
where is like the the fry box is in the
shape of [ __ ] in is Goku's head missed
fries sticky noses his hair oh I'm gonna
find that now yes I just search for like
Dragon Ball food and then like there's
like a little it looks like takoyaki or
something but that's not as good it's
like I mean it's like it's like it's
yeah yeah it's not like fully I'm really
scared this is gonna crash this dream
though if I do this do we dare I guess
we dare going on
nothing's going on it's just one image
I'll stand in the middle the arena so
you can play a clear shot
this is gonna be the funniest moment
when I break this where the hell did it
go
is it a PNG like a transparent not a
Pandi well so you can get the
transparency on it oh that's a good
point
and you get one have to look up PNG
[Music]
is that one this one's look like it nope
oh there's a little Goku
Dragonball food things to whatever I'll
just show it to you guys regardless
maybe they'll go actually food heroin I
was gonna say me Babar how did you get a
read by have no idea as a last resort
maybe I was gonna say maybe I'll open up
a ring match see if I can get people to
just join me yeah what do you guys think
about that question about that huh yeah
you want to eat some of that if it gets
better if the stuff gets bad we can just
play well play what do you guys like
better is universe or fighters uh I'm
guessing Joey hasn't played very much
he's never played very little universe
yes not really my style like fighters is
right at my out cuz I've played Marvel
Marvel Capcom for years and years
uh for me Aussie boy I have probably
played a little bit more than Joey in
terms of like universe but like not that
much more but I think I've personally
what pick Fighters because I'm really
not as vested into the story in the war
as much as it is just really cool to
have all these characters in a very
stylized fighting game yeah that plays
very like well too so I would I
personally prefer fighters for those
reasons but I can see why the universe
has a lot of appeal as well how how does
the game feel playing on a controller at
velocity velocity bear
I like playing on pad it's a little bit
um you gotta get used to it because you
do need your l1 and l2 for your assists
whereas you know a stick has you know
more freedom for all the buttons but
it's definitely playable on stick
pretty doable combo I see I think we
should just play like a local mess and
calm it down
oh no friend alert yeah yeah yeah look
at that oh I wasn't a to combo though
but he doesn't know that okay yeah the
chat doesn't know I'll get that ssgss
good either
I didn't see it it's a piece still on
cooldown
don't call him it just so you guys know
it's fighters ooh it's like fighters
yeah we got corrected at e3 but oh so if
you see in the corner orange or blue
numbers blue numbers means you coulda
TechEd out of that combo and orange
contains you pretty much can't because
it's like a true convoy
[Music]
you wanna just quit out I played Budokai
3 on ps2 so you guys recommend these
Universal fires oh he like fighting
games I definitely recommend fighters oh
is this that's so cranky any message jet
lagged on oh do we try this which one in
youtube I feel like it might have won
against the Blues yeah we'll try that
soon you literally I just still don't
leave they hold a new test we know what
will happen to train more like vs.
yeah but it would order apparently
Vegeta finally won a anime map last
night because he was able to beat the
Goku voice actor oh yeah we're up to
nine frames yeah don't worry doc we're
gonna deal with it show the menu the
main is pretty straightforward it's what
you saw in the lobby oh yeah get not
true combo because you're not checking
out of it
please don't leave this guy Joey even
though you're lagging like crazy here
we'll show you some good I'll show you
some good matches after this we'll just
play local 2 also so that group can try
to [ __ ] talk me and say I'm not I don't
know what I'm doing get out the salty
bucks if you guys know about salted guy
just kill him let's go you can style on
me later I'm trying to kill him takes me
a couple minutes get over to him see I
can't even check out this cuz I don't
know just and button countered
oh my lord get teleported on okay the
problem with hit is that he doesn't have
any faster load oh he doesn't know so is
that you need to mix up some type of mix
up to get you yeah it's like it's just
left right mix oh here we go
Oh get your salt bucks out salty bucks
out did you did you use salty bit I did
a long time ago it was fun when it first
came out I like the concept in there
yeah it's like watching the live stream
and then like switching between those
two windows to see how you're doing
sorry man I gotta jet yeah no we're not
we're not no thanks I think it earlier
someone mentioned the they won't see
some of the avatars sure I can do that
over here matchmaking yeah get out of
there man the story takes like 8 to 10
hours I think Ozzy boy so pretty meaty
right so he wants some war still there's
there's definitely still some of that in
this game but uh so these are the two
pre-order bonuses you get the the blue
go clear Vegeta right here also hit I
didn't watch any Dragon Ball super so I
barely know who those people are ginyu
so perfect so Crillon okay he's out
already right yeah yeah they're all out
soon day 18 17 is part of her toolkit
Frieza final form little weird cuz like
his level 3 is like his like beefy
version for who like Frieza turns into
like his really buff version yeah 3 is
that hit is that what he looks like here
no it's when you do that level 3 in the
air that come that's perfect version
like he gets like it's like each form a
Frieza was like he got bigger and bigger
and the final form was the smallest Oh
what what why pick will like you I don't
know it's he watched Naruto nope okay
liz is what this is Golan I'm to his
hair that's young Gohan with bowl-cut
it's like super it was like before he
knew even before teens not stylish
golden Frieza you have tin with his gay
casual trunks casual just Goku black
he's right there in the background who's
this guy for girls
Jessie I finished Jace it's one again
use boys c-murder Jason boy all right
Nina guineas boys it's Android 17 here
Cyberman always have ate the cabbage
thing well ciao suit and Bulma yeah
Frieza second transformation is a lot
like a xenomorph that's true
ooh boom oh you were there what all
right there you go
can you not move our YouTube oh god what
now I'm locked out of this no because
you're in training
you're not inverses so I think only one
of us can be there back out why can't I
control it that's really weird
okay I don't know because maybe I
started on this one
vocal okay because it's like a like to
the game it thinks it's like a
single-player thing since when did this
game decide you still let you change
your skin Marvin that's only the avatars
so there's a blue Vegeta and are we
going team Goku you want to try that
you can't hit finish sure we can do that
if it happened you can technology do it
just make sure it doesn't die yeah pick
some colors
I doesn't have a black not yes lakyn go
team oh you didn't purple either I'll go
I'll go blue or purple purplish blue
oh you're going purple okay well
whatever whatever it doesn't matter it
really doesn't matter I mean normally I
would worry about fashion but not right
now okay so what what stage do you think
it would work on space space space so if
you guys didn't know there's dramatic
finishes in the game we've done a
compilation like two compilations out
with different dramatic finishes we
could potentially show you some of those
if you guys are curious if you haven't
seen them but I have a theory that hid
might be able to do one on Goku if not
maybe Vegeta but in the anime I'm almost
positive that hit like essentially pokes
a hole into Goku blues chest there might
be a good intro oh we should do it next
time - it was boom first okay his jaw
was he he was friends yeah later
yeah how can you beat a team of Goku's
yeah did you see that guy who put like
the the text over it just like I have to
put the team through these go cos intros
dialogue put your salty bucks in I like
it I like it I like it
oh that damn no oh
face what I know yeah water damage yeah
Goku black baby
[Music]
I don't mean to do that kind of instant
- so instant air dashes forward with the
did that work yeah oh that's smart
I see you perfected your protecting of
you're just a little boy there that's
why I got a preserved blue for the
potential dramatically named
[Music]
he's in fact oh don't worry that all the
characters for now yes
yeah none of that
I want to kill him your lady film but it
needs to be lastly I know - what you
sure it's because yours on cold I hear
you guys I'm gonna let them beat me now
so that we can try to do this romantic
16:18 are you counting 21 yes I guess
technically yeah I don't like 18 but
I've seen some good stuff some people
dancing this stuff at agent fees
sparking if you didn't know what that
was it's like pretty much like x-factor
obviously if they use on your character
is more effective then if you use it on
your first you can make music extend
combos his really a ground-based
territory be careful here so normally to
initiate it it would just be a heart
attack
we'll see find out okay maybe it's one
of those weird Easter Egg ones where you
just did a super Mario level three and
it changes it again to get my run back
like I was almost assuredly going to win
that game matches rigged
kind of figure out when you're gonna
feed your throws on the throws
[Music]
oh I must that one that's a special
attack oh did you point at the ground
was that point at the gown oh is that
like kids like bang yeah
[Music]
[Music]
smack
[Music]
long map system one which map that
nexium I thought it would be in space
but if it's on space please tell me what
[Applause]
[Music]
I got that too
yes you can do it behind you good
nice comment oh oh I'm getting confused
sparking what's his level three ships
trying to see what Goku's Blues will be
like oh it's that crazy animated thing
[Music]
well that grabs me even if I walk now
it's got a way for the sparking good go
away
oh it doesn't work I thought it would
just track you
so what Matt do you think would be what
NASA yeah yeah I I'm gonna go back and
look canyon probably that's where it
wasn't me all right we're going to the
canyon alright okay the thing is day or
evening oh yeah you don't got to I both
got gyros okay
X zoom day or evening we need to know
try some some TN some young shot oh yeah
I got hit though right yeah what sijjin
oh yeah a team orange sort of blue all
right so what did we say Canyon so the
rocky field noon or evening noon or
evening I feel like there's a lot of
them already in the game that are in the
evening or in evening he thinks he
thinks evening you hide remember let's
try not to punch each other on to
another area
he just had dinner okay thanks
wait what Oh in the enemy laughter so
you go you go eat some ramen and then
just poke a hole through so much just
Elijah all right someone's a day well
we'll see
Canyon wise it should be evening cannon
wise okay thanks Bob and thanks exomes
and X SUSE mmm okay I have them laughs
so we can do whatever
what oh sorry
I'm top with the wreckage
it's a good thing to do and you played a
lot supposed to be able to do that
multiple times yes so that's only as
level 3 oh it's a level 3 and it's you
can spend a bar to do like a ton of
damage but it also takes his life as
well thanks for watching tragic the war
cries
[Music]
oh he has a dive kick double kick
[Music]
oh let me show go home in Natchez rig
because we're testing a dramatic finish
[Music]
just say to you I forgot now you won't
die for your crimes all you have seven
bars holy crap I can't believe in links
maybe I could do it faster
hi I'm out of here No look at you gain
your life back I know that's how strong
sparking little do is having saying you
did nothing to me
get that one wrong
oh that just put me right are you all
right try again apparently we don't know
how to house it's hard just he was
trying to swag combo you trying to swag
combo can't even rig this I told you I
told you gue should have bet on me
I think that was his deflect this
reflected
[Music]
I get on with that
oh my brother Oh style I got it
[Music]
seven spicy
goodbye ciaossu oh yeah
like that the other side here pulled
their healthy young cousin Duke Lacrosse
up though
oh one
all right here we're rigging the Madi
and rigging it yeah I'll just do keep it
simple just keep me in the middle I was
just gonna stay oops I'm just gonna
stand in the way but you can sit if I if
I end it with uh all right I'm just
gonna like jab me out
[Music]
well luck ice no no no that was daytime
then yes
or will it really be the like a
different suit like a level-3 I don't
know it's hard to say
let's put actually that is nighttime you
want to do intro yo see if they have a
future together
that didn't look like night that that is
the nighttime version that's like
evening no there's no there's no like
look you can differentiate rocky field
noon rocky fields even the Sun is said
we're going to noon
yeah let's go noon maybe he eats dinner
really really early in the day I know
some people that do that right lady
dinner like four o'clock they might be
starving right unless I slept like at
9:00 like no sleep at like 7 o'clock
early geez what time they waking up to
am yeah probably I mean when when I when
I work nights that's I used to sleep
like I did in the anime yeah yeah 10:00
in the morning I'm just explaining to
you guys that we can only pick from two
math yeah
oh my god are you hot Oh sue he hired me
to do
yeah he's a separate character you can
earn them through arcade or buy them for
a crapload of Zetas or I have
pre-ordered are we playing or what do we
do
[Music]
counter
what is that which one that way oh yeah
yeah you needs to be in the air though
you know Bettina doesn't walk out huh
[Music]
oh wow it's so fast that's why it does
his level three is that supposed to work
with that wall down onto the wheel on
supposed to work Oh need to mash that oh
yeah that's his Corsica four okay no
wonder he was doing nothing when he was
like in the air okay it was dark so it
can't be too early in the day
oh absolutely nice and easy
airborne afterwards yeah way it should
not be saved
I bet idea there we go
can you even did some I stuck with
Frieza you know I thought I'm
remembering we golden Frieza that's not
it as steroids Pisa
[Music]
that projectiles too good
see even goes through freezes
[Music]
all of the counter let's do it as much
damage as I'd hope
[Music]
Wow you can dash through the him
nationally the vanishing what do you
mean I was trying to manage the whole
time vanishing punch yeah I guess
there's like a little bit of startup on
that
oh wait we're supposed to try that one
which one hit killing those two on oh
wait maybe you're right okay I thought
we just picked the stage to do oh okay
let's do it let's try it I keep
forgetting that the assist goes away you
could get
[Music]
try that in the air because then you can
do a launcher after that down s cousin
launching down this
doesn't like your cake boxes Bolivians
I think yeah cuz down - down up down
the seams are two goods they're probably
all gonna be tough here
[Music]
oh damn you did oh you don't even have
hit anymore
oh well forgot
Oh
yeah I like to see certain characters
tell us and God I saved my meter
do it anyway yeah there's a lot cynical
still missing
yeah I feel like we got we got a good
the number of them but now though the
the blue sands are out
[Music]
God knows it
what else a mistake No when in doubt
shaggy doesn't like you Japanese dub
also he might need to be done with stage
destructed
[Music]
hybrid elephants asking for characters
on the roster so we can just quickly go
through it go
see em Yamcha Gohan as an adult fill-in
don't goo Frieza Android 18 Kid Buu
right here
captain ginyu nappa Vegeta the SSG SS
version Android 16 cell beerus vegeta
trunks another Goku go tanks piccolo
Gohan has a team majin buu hits and Goku
black Bob Jones yeah we don't have
Android 21 unlocked I haven't finished
the story yet
[Music]
go trucks
what you gonna do I don't know I'm
trying to see if I can get a I guess I
can't
[Music]
beerus read I don't like a teen runaway
I think he can just download and while
Walker for free now we'll try that later
might've been collectors I don't know do
you have any one of your team that's
guitar out for destructive traumatic
really I was gonna put someone on there
depending on who you pick but I didn't
really do a good job of that
let's go space anyway you don't go to
either do that 18 killing Connell yeah
that's why I picked the two of them oh
you don't like I don't like that I don't
like either the characters to be honest
yeah you said you don't like the really
shiny Carol yeah I hate the short poke I
don't like it
review when the review and progress is
out the final review probably later
today because we just wanted to be able
to test internet connectivity we weren't
having good luck though actually just
now so so we can we can go back out
there for more matches this could be fun
I don't know
[Music]
[Music]
several different days later
you know sir
that's easy Little Italy don't worry I
got curling he could be Regina
I can check out of there
like it I like two beers a near public
record he has an extra kid
that's always a big game out killing
[Music]
Beauty some know
Oh No
[Music]
how does he still so much faster do all
that should be recovering yes feeling
as banda
why did I do this to myself
[Music]
that was batida Jesus boots that is
really good I think he has like a lot of
kids while good fast normals
[Music]
oh I had to do it had to see if it would
reach you out there we're at a big
deficit here
that work
level three okay go through yes oh we
were playing on a ps4 pro I can't I
can't do it again I hate fighting
against Vegeta - his recovery is too
fast so hard to get in an attack after
block yeah you just gotta figure it out
or am in cover with the cyst or
something I try to be patient was gonna
be something there's definitely
something Oh Goku black we haven't
really done I use them but yeah better
combo and I do his dive kicks even with
a white kid booth I love that we go all
way to team team brute
yung-chun Napa finish I have Napa
quite funny of the red radiating energy
is there sparking blast so it's like
their comeback mechanic basically which
if you press all four attack ones at
once it causes you to regen your health
and your regen health and gives you more
damage yeah you did you buy collectors
no no I just want the regular dude yeah
so like it's probably possibly why he
doesn't have to only one because doesn't
be the story over there to do the
extended air combo is it l and what yeah
yeah like medium double jump like medium
yep and then I said that guys in the
joke so don't just do that one two three
four if you can order I see I see what
you're doing that oh okay I tired every
day
[Music]
yeah today you better respect it
god save me boo
have no idea what big bruise in your
median community oh that's so slow it's
got to be a you have to go to like light
hard I think oh it has to be I think
it's something like that cuz like you
can't do like me doing it it just it
there's like too much two legs on the
medium I think if you do light medium
prep like pouch immediate yeah I think
the price did nothing do we know if the
oh just like Napa or who have more
health I hope so
[Music]
see slow whichever react oh he's good
thing I know how to use Android 16 he
has like a different injury usually you
want to do it with like a critical sac
in the air and like medium is that that
does the grab a slams him down okay well
maybe you are globally after that
we sit
Oh
oh it's right there
just yeah just just do it
we're pretty far behind a little
he's always up no come on he's got no
life right we've got no life right
[Music]
that was so close how do you stop the
shark all you have to do is it a Corsica
back are to run it back
I think it's our to art but that's the
one that takes so long he likes stands
there for a second and binge okay we
could've like
cabbage
what heavens man come out he's coming oh
he's got such a big hitbox
give me God he sucked
he doesn't suck I just stuck with them
what's up agency
here's why only place a I mean they are
really good
there's like I think backwards he does
the the one like the rising oh of course
we're before so you have to kind of
judge where they're at on the screen
[Music]
can we put down
Oh
well let's see head right there sparking
[Music]
saw me pause I can't he's working yeah
who's the one getting rekt I am but
that's because I honestly have only
played five characters and I just played
three characters that I don't know how
to play so here to make myself look less
worse I will pick a team that I've
actually played I think early on when we
when we first got our hands on the game
I thought Frieza would be like one of
the top tiers because of like his
projectiles are pretty good I'm slowly
realizing that there's a lot of other
better characters actually the way I
should balance it is just pick one
character I don't know or at least have
one character yes we can't pay the very
least learn them on you
I'm just rigging it that's all you're
rigging it yeah because this should work
yeah
Wow $10 huh are you gonna bet are you
gonna venmo me if you uh if you lose
there is this evil oh yes Frieza thing
and I don't know the others it's rigged
only in the sense that this
[Music]
you know what we haven't done yet we
haven't gotten Shenron it's because
we're not doing Auto combos yes the
thing
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh please
[Music]
I'll let non-law damage you
ah
[Music]
that's so spotty not inspect
[Music]
I knew teleport is a bad idea
I am try I just try to let it rip oh you
know where we need to go down yeah I do
that was the whole point
[Music]
oh well we need its destructive oh yeah
it isn't good
[Music]
[Music]
so how do i distract with you maybe try
just to level three yeah penalty
this is pretty destructive er here yeah
there we go
see you later Vegeta
I have to finish you with it you do get
the idea
there we go
also if a picture-in-picture is covering
the subtitles I think we can we can
maybe move that to the nice yeah
Adrienne we I think they they haven't
announced the characters yet but they do
have was it six or eight characters in
that light that there's like a leak one
if you believe the loop yeah clues like
for the Rolly Rolly Rolly and some
Brawley it's finally slowest [ __ ] though
now to eat now to play one legit man
before we switch characters
watch them today
Oh lovely
[Music]
just age you ever see someone track you
like that from far away just hit age as
they're coming down cuz you gotta
vulnerability friends yeah I think you
can even do that in the air because
everyone has via the air long for as
well
oh come on Vidya
[Music]
all dockets
and death
Oh God try to telephone
[Music]
I have to burn the reader suck it up
[Music]
it's no big Gina of Isis
[Music]
with our help
[Music]
Oh cause it's parking with them
[Music]
we always go through
you can't play as dr. Rosie
Franco did the story
[Music]
rap okay landed I wasn't sure if it was
gonna work hit a button
oh you do yeah I was like you can get my
nose like maybe I can get my little
three out in the air
yeah jet ob team purple let's go
brace yourself where did you want me to
put the pit I was gonna say maybe like
above I don't wanna the bars on the like
lower right foot maybe like a little bit
higher no it's just just an idea he
could either move up to you joyful
steering
Orang Asli doctors she's a nervous
[Applause]
Veon bison
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
we want to know a piccolo our favorite
namo
[Music]
[Music]
no you're gonna okay you'll regret your
decision
although
[Music]
yo pics help me out sit me up
[Music]
hoho
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
now we like the Japanese
[Music]
don't worry go Honda save you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey guys that this hashtag it was almost
a rig trying to level 3 with their
manager
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
always inside
Oh No
so what exactly is the deal with the
untell like Wyatt in my time here
oh he's watching everyone left right
about it like my top
he's like a you seem to be like the butt
of a lot of jokes and some things
[Music]
don't worry okay do the yarmulke change
yeah we got we'd have to switch you yes
he could you do another one in the
meantime
was it look at that damage on that
oh shoot that's not it huh that works
whoops sorry that's how it should work
yeah whoops I always forget that you
have to actually just do the [ __ ]
hard hit which is why are you running a
DBZ live Shane if you know nothing about
DBZ it's a good fighting game like I
don't know all the cannon reward doesn't
mean that I can't enjoy the game Joey
knows nothing about DBZ and he likes the
game so I love the game so far I don't
know you know how to play an apathetic
not really th shinja team scrubs team
good guys over I almost have team bald
but Frieza a hit on there we need Yamcha
oh wait guys let's start with Billy yes
I was
I pretty much haven't watched very much
since Dragonball Z do rocky field noon
Yamcha is the Bloods delicas he's the
weakest as a fighter Z fighters though
he dies a lot and he guys girl taking
like the treatment yeah right thanks
Alexander Wayne appreciate the lore and
all of them Vegeta is not God Tyr he
loses every fight except for last night
I'm going to say it Yamcha is a good boy
usually try to convince bandai namco to
make a chi chi DLC I don't like everyone
that wants all these like random
characters
[Applause]
gardening here
Oh flashbang not that good
are they go away sir the time he flashes
oh hey didn't know he had that that's
how you ran away from Frieza he does
that please run away from cities oh
except it's like way like a bigger scale
[Music]
[Music]
oh I was gonna sacrifice cows ooh yeah
yes that is the solar plant
Destructo disk is ass damn it I wasted
my mirrors and if they landed get him
out of there
oh no it's not really haha you gotta get
coking black out of there well love
Barry oh and we're just playing on we're
local
well the lobby you saw the pic right
right we're in the West I just did
Krillin spinning disk attack it got
blocked for medium on everyone Oh miss
it
oh no or not I'm gonna say just try it
but I guess not okay Joey good all right
we're gonna do like a couple more
matches we're terrible at following
instructions yeah we go see Shenron well
we didn't I didn't mean to like end him
with an H that was going to punt him
[Music]
[Applause]
one two three four
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh [ __ ] snapper I almost killed you
get them out of there before I kill one
accident
oh let her live press the mediums is it
lightly
that's how on the ball you gotta jump
down
mr. motto composting oh yeah you can do
it from outcomes or you can do like like
it's either that okay guys generally and
then you need seven bars and then
landing all accountable you go for it
[Applause]
what do I want on the five seconds to
choose alternate Ali the open fire just
gives okay the ultimate power gives you
an extra sparking blast but like if you
don't if you already use it use it then
is probably better
no it stopped it
the novel's stupid but in here
that's sparking my time go the other way
oh shoot he's gonna say something huh hi
skip that oh yeah goob full health is
pretty pretty good if you come back a
character revival so you can revise a
character with like 15 or 20 percent
health or so but it's like if you only
if you only have one character left the
one that you revive is random oh okay I
think to make me immortal
jab
so you don't get as much a meter doing
here you
or them to be my
[Music]
oh there's another one nice
I am the worst
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
whereas what's together
[Music]
ah I can't fall in seconds
I really
[Music]
till mountain that's okay well if you
didn't know he does it back to Napa the
captain is there anything what else you
want to try going on back online it
pardon me after playing out there like
an hours like yeah I think I made the
right choice
I don't know I just like there's more
for me to chasing for me it's just like
I'm just a lab monster just being crazy
mood all day with its own twist
it's got guilty gear stuff in it too so
and it's probably some BlazBlue stuff as
well so yeah very very very reminiscent
of Marvel vs. Capcom series as a whole
who's got the 3v3 tag team switching oh
it's good what is that
piccolo with the Goku backwards count
that's great so with that let me check
this shop I can buy some Z capsules yeah
loot bucks boom ball boy where's this
one
[Music]
demon crown those are the Vegeta colour
go thanks color premiums equines
so those if you collect ten of them you
can redeem it for a different loop box
which gives you like a I think one that
you don't have a lot of people got that
pickle oil with this hat
[Music]
oh he wants a piece oh it's LA no oh
where you going
give balm some food here
apparently the piccolo at the Goku hat
is from them taking a driving test such
episode
[Music]
yeah it's been a good week of streams so
just wanna say thank guys all for tuning
in we show him every day at 11:00 almost
almost every day Wednesdays we will try
to fill for the time being as the lobby
is kind of just ran its course so I'm
gonna do some other stuff instead of the
lobby but Wednesday's will kind of be up
in the area I'll try to fill it as often
as I can Monday we're gonna be once 200
Monday with Ben and John Luke they'll
probably do some more high ranked hunts
try to get some people in drop those
room codes in Tuesday we're gonna check
out that cod DLC so yeah stay tuned for
that if I don't have something Wednesday
maybe I just revisit destiny twos big
update even though destiny 2 is kind of
a dead game now and then I don't know if
I've decided my sister's in Friday but
stay tuned for that guys bunch of cool
stuff happening soon so see for a match
I just got a squad for that win with no
Mike pretty good near an plays that's
something we want to do too yeah I be on
Tuesday but definitely gonna check out
caught on Tuesday Bob so maybe we'll do
IV on Wednesday or something if we don't
have anything I'll for sure be doing at
least like a little mini let's play
featured on IV masterwork armory raid
for our my stuff oh that guy's got the
beer so what do you got right there is
this guy no put tart pop tart pan oh
this guy yeah
that's Nia's trash I still kind of
defend it it's definitely not in as good
of a place as I want it to believe like
it's fine
your age I am fire lightning 68 I'm in
the same lobby as you who is XX Smith
plays you see fire lightning 68 68 where
are you fire lightning meet meeting
could be joined by in the arena
I tried showing need Red Dead Redemption
- says
Ranger - yeah I supposed to be like was
it like spring so what's up el lizard er
possibly from Puerto Rico a lot of
people train mode yeah I wish I could q
well entry moon paladin's battleground
that will be mildly interesting I guess
we'll see how that goes it's kind of
interesting to see a hero shooter still
keep tits like what if could you
envision overwatch being a battleground
that's weird
that's basically what paladin's is
intelligence is essentially like a
ripoff of a lot like how do you how do
you balance that with like all those
different classes yeah this one's a joy
to learn because fortnight's doing like
they have to balance in terms of like
the weapons because they still have like
different tiers of weapons but that's
about it
I'm gonna try the arena match
[Music]
what are you stretching when it helps
girl leave that house injustice - I like
the justice to you but I think for for
me at least I've been more of a Capcom
fighter growing up yeah I did play some
world combat I played a lot of two and
three but I kind of stopped after that
but I don't know I've always been more
of a Capcom fighter I guess I think in
just yeah same here
like the injustice bat or just combat
system was kind of took me a little
while to get used to it's because I
didn't I didn't play any mortal combat
other any other new ones and the other
one games but it you know it is really
fun like I really liked the multiverse a
lot
I never thought that's it have that much
fun playing a plane against the computer
so much his bp's not that high shaggy
cuz he hasn't played that many matches
yet i found matches faster than data yes
potentially true they're doing this guy
no rooms found
[Music]
are we just sitting on what reason we're
in the West Coast whining yes
quickly but I hope you feel better and
have a good day it's the best I can do
for you who knows when the new trailer
will be Ranger - well I'm sure if there
is a new trailer and something like that
we'll be covering it so just stay tuned
come on everyone get into this arena
match did you make a room or are you
trying to join I just talked to this guy
right here oh okay
Naji semi we would fight other players
in a lobby or watch other players fight
sorry to put you on the spot but what'll
it be
Donna Royce s Pierre Brown who did the
review I saw him play one match of
multiplayer earlier but I didn't ask him
how I was going we're trying to casual
see if that were casual if you don't
have the blues it costs a lot things
like five hundred thousand how do you
play with friends as a lot pool so you
and your friend would have to pick and
make sure you're on the same server so
you know west coast to East Coast one
whatever make sure you're in the same
server I mean I think the easiest way to
do an arena match and then set a
password on it and then join your
friends arena match it's a little bit
more complex than you would think but I
guess that's that's just what I heard at
least yeah that's what Don wood said so
[Music]
yeah I wouldn't be shocked if not as
many people are trying to get matches
and competitive and do you know if it
locks you to only the people playing in
your server I would assume so yeah
that's like your UI against any West
Coast two people right no so it's like
specific lobbies for each like a region
west coast one Smith no wait that's not
true is it
this is meeting Lobby five might be West
Coast five then I picked one with not
full people am i following any anime
this season as fears the cat anything
stood out to you I've been watching
black clover if you like bleach or
Naruto is kind of in the same vein I
started watching Overlord season two
overlords like the first season came out
a while back so it's kind of like
someone's stuck in the RPG world except
he's like this demon Overlord guy what
else am i watching this season there's
one more anthem for what it was
I can't remember it but those two are
the ones that may leave an attention to
you
[Music]
what are you doing trying to wring match
Oh how's the game so far worth it ah she
oh she Takeda I haven't played that much
outside of local stuff here but I find a
lot of fun local I know the story is
like 8 plus hours I think I think and
then there's like pretty difficult
Arcade Mode that you can do to try to
earn the Blues if you can beat it on
hard which apparently is not that easy
right Joey
ok wait say again the arcade is not easy
but it is not easy I mean the first
three that you can get through are ok
but then it gets you yeah it just gets
really difficult come on guys so if you
like fighting game so you like Dragon
Ball I think that it'll definitely
scratch that itch for you the only other
big game out right now if you're not
already playing something from maybe
last year that's out today is Monster
Hunter world of course we stream that
we're gonna continue streaming that on a
weekly basis so come back for that I
know old Bo gown I can't say it right
but yes I'm summer Colin is correct
you're the best at this game Jesse sweet
how come I don't see you at the top of
the ranks play with me play with me
turtle box TV says I know the game just
came out but who do you think is top
tier that's always like really hard and
when the game comes out when it first
comes out because certain people will
place some stuff that seems like it's
gonna work like really well yeah
day 1 day 1 like I said like Frieza you
thought was gonna be like really good
you know then you start playing other
characters they're like ah like the meta
will evolve you know a lot with it even
within like the person 1 yeah I'm sure
there will be some top tier though
I don't know I've seen some insane like
combos with a lot of characters so like
there's like a Goku black like corner
combo that like you can do like three
dive kicks yeah so it's like that's a
good one
there's crazy stuff out there for sure
we're not that high level huh which game
do you think i should buy guys Metal
Gear Solid 5 or fallout 4 Wow
both are very lengthy games depends I
guess
have you played either the series like I
think that would help influence your
decision this is not working huh no I'm
gonna give you like two three more
minutes
maybe if I post if I post the the
stickers name is old it kind of Frieza
there's no what do you want to play Oh
John Doe says a lot of people seem to
like Frieza and Kid Buu right now yeah I
don't know hard to say I mean you were
playing a lot of K blue and it seems
like you're kind of off him now yeah
lightning oh I'm there oh okay all right
all right Joey Oh what what is all those
coins that you don't know all right
bring it on Smith oh hey Benny that's my
that's my that's my bet money bah pecan
pankaj chowder hurry I'm sorry if I
butchered your name they're gonna add at
least six maybe eight more Susie up at
all those six are a breather
[Music]
you guys later for the match
where are you get hit all right let's
see who's got our shipping regular who
did he just kind of use wow what the
hell is going on I have no idea oh
you're getting day one right now -
getting day one spam I can't even tell
who's who because you guys are so
similar so similar all the good thing is
you keep learn to sparking
[Music]
JK
that's terrible
good luck it little bit leg six hit is
Kamisama my best character he's got
[Applause]
yeah playing on 19 and you just pulled
this you must have been pulling the plug
he's moving his router hiding it in a
box
woo-wee we are slow-mo slow-mo animate
for dramatic effect
that's so anime
yeah
Oh yep to go have war Vegeta you know
who always wins cool with just battle
underwater in the lava its whoever does
the the chase down learn more about way
oh I think you could have sparking
[Music]
Oh what that's still tracking that's
what you get that's what you get oh I
think the the says I got a new medal so
those little emblems out the bottom of
the name like is bad yeah it's bad
it started off fine and you liked it
GG yeah that was so can we still read
the back where is it this is just 100 is
so for that lobby 19 frames GG for a
second oh man
good day one play I like it have their
servers been rough so far it's not so
much the servers as much as it is like
if you're getting a kick like what fire
lightning 68 is a hot red no bar I
didn't even realize that his connection
was for
it lagged hard yep definitely a lag card
where is the lobbyists I can rough you
up I told you West Coast zero it was
like meeting meeting Lobby five yeah but
if that's the one that's in one of those
pretty sure it's Westco zero five
Christoph M you can't just power up
within the game but that's not how it
works and you know there's like separate
characters I mean yeah you can
technically as spicy for he says as like
Goku you can go like Super Saiyan level
three and super kind of the same with go
adult Gohan he has like a team super
where he SS Jays two tenses and gets
still good right now you got to take
advantage Joey before it's too big oh
that was nice
[Music]
I don't want to do food it's not gonna
say anything they didn't see why is it
seems like it's a lot better already
so you're not able to edit your team at
on that or nothing
I think you can one two three I hope
you're not pressing black go tanks paint
it for me all right I see what we're
doing right now yeah one two three
West Coast one meeting lobby 502 dad
dude you could have had a chance at
fighting me now you all know the taste
of defeat
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
okay hey China
maybe I keep using it unfortunately
oh he's got English on oh he does yeah I
think he does maybe not
no I think it's it's your own dislike
conscious specific so if they have
anyone it's not gonna fix I'm definitely
not afraid of you dude you're just gonna
try your day one stuff and it's not
gonna hurt did you do that yeah that's
me that make me immortal I really like
this one because it just gives you
health regen for the whole round
yeah can I'm not your kid good thing you
still have health regen huh
what's up Cory to a gamer what up
alright 1 1 1 ok that what that was
unless that was fire that's fine yeah
you're definitely not
you can kind of power up if you use an
assist ninja scroll but yeah it's not
I guess that easy just the power well
you do want to switch in and out with
combos and stuff though Kristoff so all
right best of three here GG I guess so
unless noob shoe riot can get in here so
I can smack him so I can show him a
little smack hurry since he says he
thinks he's a professional at the art of
dragon fighting
unfortunately no grand say yes I say a
mango
I pay my abc dealer so I'm filling in
the lobby not hiding why you can't get
in the meeting room here I'll join a
meeting room after this to fight you
have with that
it's pretty fun Bobby's on it or Bob
lice on it
[Applause]
[Music]
there's go for the swag
they're live all right you hear that
[Music]
Naruto for more fun just family not so
to win no store for I use people other
than Minato Naruto full power is people
Oh into the volcano see you you still
people have people calling this fighters
II anymore I don't think I think like
yeah fighter see
[Music]
don't how you reflect I thought there
was gonna be more hits after that I
thought it was like bold they even try
to reflect the level three doesn't work
burned all my meter why they come back
coming back with no help
jaywalk hey he's hit you know it's
possible or get caught on a back - GG
why do people want to turn off auto
convoy so good it's really not like I
mean you don't gain me as much meter and
it's not as much yeah you don't do as
much damage but I kind of like to be
incentive to want to use it even if you
don't normally use Auto combos because
it'll still give you a random Dragon
Ball and if you're like stuck on six of
them and you can't get like a 60 hit
combo specifically you could just do an
auto combo and that'll make it a lot
easier to get it all right goo where are
you are you let's see if he's in this
Lobby so I do jeez - what was his name
in the back well it's in there it's a
fire lightning but in here it's or is it
no prize isn't there
I don't know dang it it was like xxxx
yeah something uh kippers open a second
alright is gubin here oh yeah we're
throwing down
oh come on guess come get some men
djenka what's the number of the lobby
five yeah or we should go to a more open
one is that possible oh let me here
we're gonna we're gonna try going to a
less ok wait yeah I can change the lobby
here yeah I'm ready ok Oh alas I must
say no offense to the players but
they're kind of scrub you hey man it's
day 1/2 depending on how you look at it
all the way down oh that means here just
go like pick the lowest I think pick a
westco's and then pick one of the ones
that has like the least tonight I'll do
West Coast one and then pick oh those
are what first I think they're all
lobbies but it's like specifically like
oh if you want one yeah this is where
you should go pick one and tell everyone
okay I'm gonna go to ring match first
Lobby one west coast line go make me
feel alive again while you're dead
inside
I don't think SSM you want you need to
know to spit out Zelda's like Activision
does with Cod I think would be sadly
mistaken okay yeah this is a bunch of
people with the arena matches around
here don't yet those set one up that yes
or a ring match sorry let me go
all right here green categorical is this
oh that's word one two one two three
four one two three four create the
remains so how do you change a character
in that let's take a look so we got
closed room if you play a card can you
change it from here cannot wait
that's selecting team
oh this fire lighting you found it
already goes fast
there's goob busy
oh let's guess some I need it I need to
play our controller though oh is XX
Smith plays there you go thanks that was
a save and then where's Ben Janka okay
you make a team for me then or how does
that work
there's got to be a way right you might
have to drink more you start history
oh yeah oh don't do that oh here we go
okay okay so who do you want adult coke
Gohan Goku and adult Gohan Goku black
and then toss on normal go to yeah you
can join xx Smith we're also trying to
get philanthropy and we're also trying
to get oops you ride in here are you
guys joining or what one two three four
there's been Janka yeah oh yeah
you got a little team right here
[Music]
we're gonna fire lightning so how do the
rest of them doing they should be able
to get in queue here
did you get in though goob I only see
the XS Smith X guy I like how two
matches can go on at once that's pretty
cool
one two three four is the code where's
my real rel I don't know he says I'm
getting the no rooms founder so how do
how do we fix that then hmm
[Music]
no news yet lucky it's only rumors here
maybe we can start this for the place
for the time being
oh how do i i'd have to log on to your
account with this controller you can do
that here now I just play are you sure
that's fine what are the what am I
looking at
so you're looking at ABC special that's
why sis okay just just queue up xx Smith
for now wrong room
I can join Angry Joe's game next to you
what Oh angry Joe isn't here yeah I seen
our rooms try roleplay alright so how do
we make a new one okay so hit R -
alright ring password 1 2 3 4 everything
good create a ring
we made one we'll try the try again
[Music]
SSM the game reminds you of squat tune I
love spot tune by I don't really see the
comparison or goob you can try making
one and I'll try to join a team rip air
it out mr. quarantine the the Pearson
Pearson was having some issues earlier
this morning to fight me xx mr. Smith
until they get back one two three
one to physically weird alright it's
fine
no excuses unless there's lack then
there's nothing but excuse room creation
is down at the moment that's not true we
just made one it's like down for some
people it's like kind of weird oh nine
frames here wow I can't even follow up
with it
standing medium I've been living that
local way of life
all he's sparking already that might
have been input error I can't we're
gonna have the auto combo here
people were saying I think during the
during that class living cool if you had
some mash buttons to win it
Oh does he retain his power up if you
switch our I hope so
it's all the way on the bottom right I
forgot which one I think it's LT
kind of reaction in a little freedom no
Goku shrink card is gone my best
character now hey black for supply I
like this one that's automatic normally
[Applause]
I might have to do one two three four
all right uh looks like Ben djenka has
made a room so maybe we can join him for
the last MIT last couple matches oh my
god this is now I know what you're going
through 11 1 10 frames I was playing
with almost 20 right no I spiked up to
19 this noise Oh God
there you go he's memory so if you're
sparking oh my god game Eric's 1 1 2 I'm
sorry Ninja Scroll there seems to be a
little a big split like I feel like
almost down the middle or people prefer
English over Japanese dubs
[Applause]
can you reflect it oh thanks oh it
stopped liking or something they put it
like a split second
so how do you do your instant hair if
you can't even just how do you do what
hold on
got it okay
how do you how are you doing instant air
- if you're out if it's l1 so so l1 is
also special and hard so that's why I
put the two at the bottom so it's like
like the old air - or whatever gggg
because before when I have it as like
one two three we're gonna try to find
Ben's okay yeah yeah that makes sense I
didn't realize that that was the same
thing okay that makes a lot of sense
then because I do it with a like I'm
flicking our tube on the on the pad
Danny on Twitter we are aware of the
issues regarding ring matches some of
you may or may not be okay let's try
alright no room span again the error
again just keep trying
hey what happened oh you probably
canceled it hi sauce goob make a room
hello I can eat stamps wanna play with
me
oh wow that was Aaron's found rip
really
I wonder how lightning on in Aragon says
like they says for some people it's it's
happening but not everyone oh that one
took longer than usual the hell is been
Janka where'd you run off to unless I
gave up I don't know I think I think at
that point at this point which is
college dream unless you want to play
one more mattress don't worry
oh this is Ben right down there what if
we both oh you can't cue up on speaking
south
all right it's not looking good
she's just do one just a casual match
all right well end it with a casual
casual one last one V one put your money
in the in the chat your fake money your
ones for Joey your twos for me Eric
actually it's just for Joey I don't can
you actually do that
try try eight goob and then try joining
a match in the in the actual like world
and see if it picks from or only the
lobby yeah I try it try let's just try
queueing in casual and seeing a Phil
Paris it's fire lightning not afraid of
you goob
are we in casual right now yeah okay
try a rematch we did try ready queued up
I wonder if it even works since a it's a
ring first all may thing and see why not
that was kind of slow
so there might be some ring match making
stuff going on and bank I Nemco is
already tweeted about it so just know
that
[Music]
it's clearly not working
[Music]
they're trying to fix it right now
there's some red our coal thinks Lopez
Julian it's not fighters on switch that
would be nice I'll see I don't know and
maybe on a pro control yeah I mean it
clearly not on like on uh we're cooking
the portable mode probably not gonna do
too well in that checkup own inch
strength and matchmaking it's on
everyone it's set on everything the only
thing that's not set is the connection I
don't cancel this
that's just so dang boring yeah well
what happens day one
the
I think there are some connectivity
issues as going yeah I'm not shocked by
that says here you have network
connectivity no Afghan works fine
Monster Hunter world does it pretty good
yeah see he said it's monster huh
but the thing with that though is like
even if it's um you don't have online
you still can play awfully so it's true
should we try no the server or should we
just all right fine laughs whichever
okay phone chat we're gonna go to the
emptiest of empties no you want to go to
the more oh you're just yeah oh you're
trying to get a match with them that's
why
North America
let's try try a different West Coast
server let's go let's go three
these are more for arena matches these
are ring party matches so Lobby one
apparently Lopez says that in 100 worlds
multiplayer is kind of messed up to you
but you can play safely I don't know I'm
not out there checking so don't stop
streaming I'm bored we're gonna have to
stop soon I need to get lunch
she told me come rolling Joe he's trying
to do another Dragon Ball video that
he's testing could be a good one if it
works out that's all I have to say about
that
it does right now em but it's the first
day so that's some people in arena
matches ok where'd you go hmm oh I just
look at people in the arena well how
come you're having like a Rochambeau I
think these are these are the matches
you can watch here spectate a lot of
people in arcade mode
I mean if all those fails we could just
do in arcade mode but that might take a
little while that's gonna take too long
cost like 80 viewers there
I'm gonna give you two minutes okay I
think that's fair
cuz it's been more than that aiready
well I'm gonna go spend some your
matchmaking here pause though now yeah
just get ten at a time there we go good
[Music]
would you eat what I eat now saying that
would I eat right now yes I would I'm
really hungry
[Music]
others philanthropy
should we try to wring match here if you
want to uh you can try it with Ben but
if it doesn't if it shows no room then
we're just calling it
do I dare start a ring match I think
it's gonna be about the same you'll know
at least right away if it works or not
yeah is your fight each other IRL to you
find a match that's not how it works
though like you can't just be in queue
while playing opal Oh looks like
maybe what is this they're still setting
up all right it's canceled
no room sound
all right Joey I can't I can't I
honestly can't wait anymore yeah you can
oh you're gonna create one here good
create one this is literally the last
chance last-ditch effort at least let me
create a room nope
I'll say fire lightning has been has
been able to get in here pretty pretty
easily
someone's he says he's waiting in there
one Oh ones are waiting in the arena
match all right here we'll play one
match a local play just so that this
ending isn't so awkward wait we got one
that catches fire lightning I don't want
any more lag man okay you want to just
hear what is to offline what is just do
offline super thing is we could just
told Ben to come into this room I know
gamespot this dude in the chat called me
a bad word everyone just disappeared by
the way server reboot me oh yeah maybe
this might help
whoops I pick Canada and the East Coast
see you later West Coast server three
wonder if it kicked everyone no let's go
lobby one it's just day one and my thing
I mean if it continues in a week then
yeah well we got problems to talk about
but it's just kind of how it goes hey
look it's fire lightning again maybe was
just me like I kick yeah hey look we got
a match with no legs
we got one he's my first random get rid
of great random No
we don't know Chad I bet you were ready
for a lot
[Music]
so you don't think he keeps his power up
if I tagged him out who's Ohio because
right now I should switch him with beer
he's like electrified right I'm like
when you powers up I guess I should in
theory me holding the assists will get
me here
nope nope too soon
oh that's so much easier to screw up
[Applause]
water
the green boot yeah
Oh done a boo
what
the surgeon
[Music]
that threw no idea what level six does
but can you keep doing it quite if you
mash do what super yeah like if you have
enough meter can you just mash it and
just continuously do all right you can
either tie it up where go home anyone
baby
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I've been new level one and spam button
[Music]
come on
[Music]
[Applause]
no GG did you can you play 1v1 or is it
now you always took I don't know there's
a 1v1 is it uh it says offline there's a
few 1v1 and that's I think only during
story Marie like sometimes you only have
one or two care cuz I'm versus like one
or two on there I see well thank you all
for tuning in for our dragon ball
fighters launch livestream there were
some you know a little bit of online
issues but it is day one so and I
believe Namco has been tweeting on some
stuff set and they know and they were
trying to fix it so our review and
progress is up I want to say maybe later
today or this weekend we'll have a full
review through and through thanks Joey
for a plane thank you for having me and
I know you're gonna be working on
something fun hopefully it works out
yeah I don't seems pretty cool if it
does work out thank you guys all for
tuning in come back next week 11:00 a.m.
we'll be streaming some work so thank
you everyone peace out
have a good weekend see you
[Music]